I never wanted a crown I told you I
don't want it it doesn't matter what you
want I don't want it I don't want it
Daenerys is awkward she shouldn't be you
are my queen I don't know what else I
can say you are my queen while see she
is my queen you will always be my queen
you are my queen you can't beat them in
a straight fight what they see is just
the end of the Dothraki essentially how
far good the knight king is coming
the dead are already here
and they put the women and children in a
crimp with all the dead people so rah
you're in the smart but it's not that
smart you need me okay
well if that's what it's come to we
really are focused well calling you [ __ ]
wouldn't be strictly actively calling
you [ __ ] would be strictly accurate I'm
going to go now go where
[Music]
I hope to kind of avoid the expected and
John snow has always been the hero the
one who's in the Savior but it just
didn't seem right to us for this for
this moment he climbed on the [ __ ]
dragon unfought what kind of person
climbs on a [ __ ] dragon I'm mad man
threatened me again and I'll have you
thrown into the sea you broke my nose
how did not break your nose hi garden
you could be Lord of the reach hi gone
are you mad it's better than being dead
tell her while Danny kind of forgot
about the iron fleet and Euron's forces
and the golden company has arrived in
King's Landing courtesy of the Greyjoy
fleet how did they find you did you
consider taking it off understand by one
thousands of men dependent life but
you've done it you've kept your oath
dead if not for yourself if not forever
and for every one of the million people
in that city innocent or otherwise to be
honest I never really cared much for
them innocent or otherwise
so you're telling me all these scorpions
are turning on to shoot a drug on
they're all just facing in one direction
what you just [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
Oh is she due for the manner it's her of
a treasonous brothers
if the city surrenders they will ring
the bells and raise the gates please if
you hear them ringing the bells call off
the attack how many slaves are there in
yunkai 200,000 if no more then we have
200,000 reasons to take the city there
were none of my enemies not the blood of
innocents I am NOT here to be queen of
the ashes
[Music]
I'm gonna kill them when I see one
[Music]
I can never be Lord of Winterfell I can
never be Lord of anything and three-eyed
Raven will you lead the seven kingdoms
to the best of your abilities from this
day until your last day why do you think
I came all this way I don't really want
any more the north will remain an
independent kingdom as it was for
thousands of years so our new king has
chosen to send you to the Nights Watch
I still nights watch sir Bronn of the
Blackwater Lord of Highgarden Lord
paramount of the region master of coin
I've never borrowed money before I'm not
clear on the rules a Song of Ice and
Fire
parts mystery Bros history of the wars
following the death of King Robert I
don't believe you mentioned so I'll set
up this next clip a bit and it's gonna
notice to a lot of people the clip is
regarding the final line in the show
that tyrion says and what most people
don't know is that he said this multiple
times before what a jackass and a
honeycomb into a brothel once walked
into a brothel with the honeycomb in a
jackass the madam says my ones brought a
jackass and a honeycomb into a brothel
I think this line is like a perfect
metaphor of what the dialogue and the
show has become an unfinished joke that
just moves on to the next scene in a
rush to me it just kind of feels
bittersweet and I just wanted to share
with you guys